it's interesting to see this kind of
duplicity one side wants a piece deal
with north korea but doesn't one
doesn't want one with iran the other
side is completely the opposite that's
just because they're just trying to
why can't we just have a peaceful
non-interventionist american foreign
policy which every
president keeps promising us george w
bush barack obama
you know it's popular trump no it's
popular it's the military industrial
economy
right right right they're all beholden
but they'll all be holding why do they
keep campaigning on it
we're going to end these forever awards
because they know that that is what's
popular yeah for sure
most people don't want to be george w
bush promised to be a
non-interventionist president
so did barack obama so did donald trump
donald trump i mean there's an argument
to make here because he's quasi
globalist
quasi a nationalist but he's the only
one that hasn't started a war out of all
this that's very true for and he broke
the long
time cycle for decades now of starting a
new war which does have to be kind of
looked at even though he kind of came
close to it with iran
you're the perfect example of uh i think
why trump supporters needed to do better
outreach to the left
because there's probably there's there's
a lot you've praised trump for
i you know what i see him no because i
don't just hate him because i hate him
all right like i don't have that um my
look i'm not a republican i don't
generally support their policies i don't
support their platform i'm about policy
right so
their policies are not do not speak to
me um
but i don't just slam him for just
because to slam him
but he also did the same thing with the
obama stuff he went and tried to just
undo everything obama did just to stick
it to him
so what you're dealing with is a massive
amount of man-baby egos yeah
and now biden's going to do the same
thing but i was going to one no
no joe biden is going to be putting his
wheelchair wheeled into the sunroom with
a blanket on his lap whatever he's going
to fall
out the corporate corporatist globalist
whatever he's the front man he's the
suit man but i was going to ask you
what qualities of donald trump did you
like
i like that he's anti-establishment i
like that he's not part of the machine
now he is part of his whole own machine
he is absolutely part of what i would
consider to be the oligarchy class he is
definitely part of
of that level of corporate establishment
he is definitely of the haves and not
the have-nots
his interests are definitely not the
same as the interest of the majority of
people that i
would say i would represent as a
constituency so
he is not somebody that i would support
but the things that most people dislike
about him
generally don't bother me i don't care
about his mean tweets i don't care about
his ridiculous nonsense
but what that does do is it distracts
people for the same reason we're talking
about the wrestling thing and there are
people that
don't see it as hyperbolic and that's
right right right and they weren't
talking about real issues they were
talking about ice cream
toilet paper russiagate meanwhile
distracting us from the real
actual issues the banksters the the the
corporatism
none of that was discussed at all you
could have legitimately had some real
criticism against donald trump but you
never had that at all now my issues with
him are policy based and
um when he's done things that i haven't
found objectionable i've always been
pretty vocal about like i don't i've
never pretended that
you know i hate i don't hate him and
that has actually gotten me a lot of
crap
that's okay right gravity yeah that has
gotten me
from the the left that you're speaking
of and the establishment and
specifically in our district
because i don't hate him enough you know
what you know what i've noticed a lot of
the um
a lot of the leftists like the non-woke
ones refer to the woke left as the
neolibs yeah
neoliberals and then on the right they
just say the left or leftist and i'd
like for people to understand there is a
big difference
like i feel like as somebody who's the
actual left i
we are fighting a war on two fronts
right like we're fighting and we
actually spend more time fighting our
own people
we don't have to fight republicans we
can't get past our own selves
and so the people that are the actual
and we're constantly being
viewed by people like you're probably a
lot of your audience
as the same and we're not the same right
like
very nuanced to an extent i would say
yes but i think trump a lot of trump
supporters
really like the anti-woke
anti-establishment left
you know people like jimmy dore for
instance or people like you actually so
if you if you come out and say before i
start this conversation i want to say
two things
and i'm not saying this literally i'm
just saying this figuratively yeah i'm
on the left but i think hillary clinton
is completely despicable
they're gonna be like okay okay let's
have a conversation like we can start
from there right yeah
we agree on the establishment being
awful yeah well because what we're
talking about now is you're talking
about
literal politics and that's that's
a circus to me okay i'm concerned about
policy this is this is the kind of
conversation i think is the biggest
threat to the establishment yeah that
they don't want us all being friends
right it's so it's really funny when i
see you know jimmy dore who's very left
a lot of issues
he was tweeting about medicare for all
and things like that and
the criticisms he has the democrats same
as me same as probably everybody in this
room
and that's bad for the machine i think
trump ran as a republican because it was
his path to entry
same as many progressives run as
democrats as their path to entry
but trump does not function the same way
the establishment machine did it was
democrats and republicans they were the
same thing trump got in
and he put a boot to the behind of many
of these people and so you saw the never
trumpers flee to the democratic party
all of a sudden now we have these which
isn't a stretch though and i and that's
the thing that we need to be very clear
on because the
democratic party is basically very
moderate
the same thing yeah they are like they
they're corporate i i think
they pretend to have issues they care
about they'll tell you
oh you're republican i'm pro-life just
like you and then they'll sell you out
in a moment's notice
the democrats will tell you they're for
your policy and then ignore you as soon
as they get elected
so trump gets in and it's it's amazing
to see the lincoln project right these
republicans
all of a sudden supporting democrat
candidates and i'm like you're not
republicans you're not conservatives
you're not you're just there i call them
the keys to the castle uh
democrats or keys to the castle
politicians give me the keys i'll say
whatever you want to say and then i'm
going to go inside lock the door and
just take the money and do whatever i
want
that's that's that's that's where we're
at for the most part corporatists
that's what they all are that's what
they all have that's the common
denominator they all work for the same
employer if you were to follow the money
trail from all these people and while
trump has not been a
traditional republican he has towed that
line too he has definitely fallen in
line with what i
what i refer to as what i call the deep
state you know
you think you think i think that he
has not pulled us out of the wars that
he has said he was going to pull us out
of
why well hold on hold on you know that
uh and i mean continuously like he first
started with the
we're going to get out of syria and then
that never happened you know that was
because he was lied to
there was a uh so this is a story that
came out from defense one
a federal official bragged about lying
to the to trump and the u and the
american people
about how many troops we had in syria in
order to inflate the number so trump
couldn't pull him out
okay so let me then just say this the
buck stops with him so whatever the
reason is that led him to where he is
that's where we are right so he's had he
did higher bolts
he hired john bolton that that's
and but you know a lot like pompeo's
much like gina haspel i mean these are
not he's trying to fire her
how many people kill that's true that's
true in his escalated drone war how many
people did
we don't know because they stopped the
report okay so no new wars but he killed
countless people with drugs the trump
administration
the accountability and the counting of
the drones well that's even better
but so he did get a second new war it
was a drone no no
he escalated the drone war yes but my
understanding is that
that was under bolt that was under trump
no no that was so when he hired bolton
yeah bolton was like we're gonna blow
everything yeah but again buck stops
where
it's true no trump hired a bunch of dumb
people and he and he's come to regret it
now bolton's throwing him under the bus
i hear it from a lot of trump supporters
who have said
trump who was it who said this trump
should have done the one thing he's
famous for
fire people he didn't he well and so
that to me was him
basically paying homage to the military
industrial complex and the establishment
and that is
look he's had three years and but i will
tell you this i had a very big moment
where i actually turned to my television
while he was speaking by myself and i
said thank you sir for your good candor
because he actually made a comment as to
we were in syria for the oil
yes i remember he said it in like
mid-sentence i turned i'm like
thank you yeah thank you for that but
but i kind of feel like
you know trump tried to remove all of
our troops out of syria and democrats
and republicans revolted
he tried to remove all of our troops in
afghanistan and democrats and
republicans blocked him
yes so i kind of felt like when he said
he said two things
he's coming out of the white house
there's a helicopter you know noise and
they're like you know how's it going and
he goes we got a really great deal
we're going to sell saudi arabia tons of
weapons make billions of dollars
hit pictures yes yeah remember that he
had pictures of those what the air of
the area
all of the anti-war progressives jaws
dropped and they're like he just
said it i was just so pleased admitted i
know i was laughing i was clapping for
it i was so pleased um
well i mean i thought the pictures was
the the av-8 it was a little over
but like well it was sort of like how a
little kid would draw and demonstrate
this is what we're doing
i feel like he's doing it on purpose
because so
when when he said that we're keeping 200
troops in syria they're guarding the oil
it's great
i was so pleased but they blocked him
and they lied to him i i wonder if trump
was like
all right i'm going to tell everybody
exactly why we had to keep these troops
in here because he wants to get him out
see i think that the any president that
actually really does go to do that
i don't think makes it yeah and that's
and that's just
see i think that anybody that would to
really threaten
the existence of our military industrial
complex wouldn't wouldn't live
that's just me i mean i just and the
only president that i know of that has
done that
got got dead the problem is they live at
the white house right in the belly of
the beast they'd have to go to russia
under the protection of some foreign
country then they would justify this
yeah
but then someone would step in and say
aha he fled he's illegitimate they're
taking control
still the only way to survive if you're
going gonna go against this i think i
think trump was really naive when he
first uh
got elected he he assumed that he was in
charge and he was gonna be able to play
ball with these
establishment crony individuals and they
cut they they put so many knives in that
man's back he didn't you know he but
that's the nature of the game that's
that job
he wasn't expecting to win i mean i
don't think he really wanted that job i
think he was doing it because they
basically
threatened him that you can't do it he's
like i'm going to show you yeah but i
would say one of the most important
things that trump did when he did
first go into office is he stopped
arming
the rebels inside of syria whether it
was isis al-nusra al-qaeda we do have to
give him credit for that because barack
obama and hillary clinton
they were running the same protocol that
they ran in libya overturn
you know give all the jihadis as much
money as much weapons as we can let's
overthrow the government
donald trump stopped that he did have a
limited recent withdrawal of afghanistan
and somalia but again very limited
but we have to look at this at the
greater context of american geopolitics
with
saudi arabia especially with the saudi
u.s coalition
conducting their warfare on yemen right
now which is literally creating the
worst humanitarian crisis
in the world thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm so come
back to check us out when we go live
don't forget to subscribe hit the like
button hit the notification bell and we
are also available on all podcast
platforms for free
if you want to listen to us there thanks
for hanging out and we will see you all
next time
you